I was a little bit about globalization
or the lack thereof and obviously this
idea that the virus is probably going to
reverse the trend of globalization I
think that there was this kind of
underlying tone of hey borders coming
down you know let's be more global both
on a business and also a social
component virus happens now everyone's
basically walk around with masks on
pointing at each other saying you know
forget another country hey you're from
another state right I heard those New
Yorkers they got a ton of virus over
Chicago oh no I don't want you coming
from that city maybe talk a little bit
about how that that trend reversal
globalization maker yeah you know
another state the people the suburbs are
telling the people in New York of
Chicago to go back to the city at this
point but yeah as far as globalization
goes the virus came out of out of China
you know we could leave for another
argument whether or not China did
everything that they needed to do and
it's been properly reporting probably
not and there's a lot of anger around
the world rick scott senator from
florida was on TV last week and he got
very mad and he said anybody that buys
anything made in china is immoral well
you know 60 days ago you would've been
run off as a kook if you would have said
that and as I like to say who's gonna
defend China you know there's 22,000
dead Americans is anybody a Democratic
Party gonna stand up and say Rick you've
lost your mind
how about Europe is McCrone from France
he's got 16,000 dead is he gonna say no
we have to be nice to the Chinese know
the Italians gonna say that no who's
this is global who's gonna say that
Larry Kudlow over the weekend Easter
Sunday said remember Larry Kudlow who
signed off his show I believe in free
market capitalism is the best path to
prosperity said the United States
government should pay the moving cost of
all companies that want to move back
from China okay two things about that
we're stud the free market capitalism
Larry but more importantly so now we're
ready to do they come the other
direction and I think that there's going
to be a lot of that everybody's in
agreement then at a minimum Sam
strategic stuff like pharmaceuticals
should be coming back okay why does it
stop there why are we going to now turn
to mr. cook and say why are you leaving
yourself vulnerable by making your
phones in China why aren't you making
your phones here or in Europe or in
South America or a little bit of all and
mr. cooks argument would be because it's
more efficient to make them in China and
we would come back to them and say this
is about resiliency now this is not
about efficiency anymore
that era has sailed we're more about the
resilient era then next time we have to
shut down a bit cover the economy for
three months we want nobody to have a
bailout okay think about how the balance
sheets have to look and how everybody's
business has to be straight they can be
structured for that but they they're
they're not going to give you that
forward p/e of 20 on a hundred thirty
earrings to get you back to thirty four
hundred on the SP you're not going to
have that so I think that that deep
globalization is going to push back and
then governments are going to do that
too
when people start pointing at the Trump
administration you could have done more
or the Johnson administration in the UK
you could have done more they're gonna
say it's China's fault and everybody's
going to say yeah I agree with you it's
China's fault and so and there's going
to be no natural constituency to defend
China so I do think you're going to see
some of that the globalization come down
and it's going to you know it's going to
mean less efficiency I didn't make a
qualification of whether that's good or
bad it might be necessary but it is a
reality that the reason we're in China
is it's more efficient and if we leave
we're going to be a little less so yeah
when that happens what do you think
occurs in terms of the China versus u.s.
global superpower showdown right and
what I mean by that is what you're
essentially doing is by becoming more
resilient you're becoming less efficient
and therefore can you actually produce
the goods as well probably not can you
produce them as fast probably not as
cheaply definitely not and so you get in
this weird world where do US consumers
exclusively consume then from US
companies where everything's made in the
US and
as exclusive Chinese manufacturers that
are all made in China or do you still
get the consumer kind of shopping for
lowest price and kind of benefiting from
the efficiencies but companies are the
only ones that are affected and they're
the ones that are forced to be resilient
and therefore US companies end up
actually losing because they lose that
efficiency yeah I think you know first
of all that efficiency or that
resiliency will come over time it won't
happen immediately you know we won't
just wholesale pull out of China we will
start to pull out of China over time I
think from the Chinese perspective
they're gonna be under enormous pressure
because they're going to see their
growth rates peak and they're gonna
start coming down keep in mind the
following about China in the United
States there's nine cities that have a
million or more population and there's
ten cities in Europe that have a million
or more population in China there's over
30 and we learned a new one called Wuhan
that had more people than New York City
probably before November nobody knew
what one was as well
there's 1.4 billion people in China
every year the population of Canada
about 22 million people in China migrate
from the farms in the rural areas which
are really third-world to the cities
which are really first world in China
there's modern is any city and they're
looking for a job and as long as China's
growing fast they could bring those
people and then show up sometimes with
no shoes on and they say here sit down
at this thing and do this like this or
you know 414 wine a day and you can send
it back to your family on the farm and
they're happy to do it
now they come to the city you don't have
that growth rate anymore
and they don't have that and there's
going to be resentment and anger and
they pile up in the ghettos in these
cities and they get mad why don't I have
a job and they create a lot of social
unrest in China so China is going to be
under the gun to try and rectify this
now the way that China is going to
rectify this I think is real simple is
Chuck needs to be more transparent let
the world in let the world see what's
going on
the next time three people have a coffin
China people from the West can go down
and see is this a pandemic or is this
nothing instead of waiting for you to
give me you know your spin and hide it
the Chinese government's never communist
governments never going to do that so
they're gonna have some change on this
flip side we're gonna have that change
too
we're gonna have to see us pull back
while we pull back I think it's going to
fall on the companies themselves in
order to eat that loss their margins are
going to have to get squeezed over time
it will be only be as the process is
unfolding is that you're going to see
then then be able to pass those costs
along because remember I think what's
going to happen is companies are going
to be forced to become more resilient
there's gonna be rules there's going to
be twisting of arms you got to get out
of China or something like that and then
they're going to get out of China but
then they always won't be the lowest
cost producer but they're gonna have to
be forced to price to the lowest cost
producer and that's gonna make them
squeeze their margins and as well - so
this will be a process that will take
some time and again I'm not suggesting
that this is catastrophic in any way but
what I am suggesting is if you're
waiting for 15% earnings growth in 24
word Pease to just power the market
forever and ever that error may have
ended already and we're going into a
different type of era it doesn't mean
the stock market goes you know down 90
percent like the Great Depression but
we're not gonna go back to the old highs
for a while at least one cycle before we
can kind of figure it out